PHONY COLLISION NARRATIVE FROM
THE START.
FORMER OBAMA AND DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE
JAMES CLAPPER APPEARED ON
TELEVISION.
IT WAS IT JUST ME OR DID HE SEEM
TO STRUGGLE TO GET OUT THE RIGHT
WORDS?
>> WELL, I'M VERY CURIOUS SINCE
PRESUMABLY I'M ONE OF THOSE
UNDER INVESTIGATION.
I FOUND THE TIMING INTERESTING,
GIVEN THE INCREASING HEAT AROUND
THE IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT
MIGHT RISE TO THE LEVEL OF
CRIMINAL OFFENSE?
>> THAT'S OBVIOUSLY AN ITEM OF
GREAT INTEREST TO ME.
>> PASSED THE DEPENDS.
FOR HIS PART FORMER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI
ANDREW MCCABE ON CNN THOUGHT TO
SHIFT THE FOCUS OF THE CONDO.
>> IT THERE SEEMS TO BE WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND ATTORNEY GENERAL
AS WELL UNDERLYING LACK OF
TRUST.
IF THOSE DECISION-MAKERS ARE NOT
CONVINCED THAT THAT THEY ARE NOT
TAKING THE RUSSIAN THREAT FROM
2020 ELECTIONS AS SERIOUSLY AS
THEY SHOULD.
>> REMEMBER McKAY VISIT GUY
WHO HIMSELF IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
PERHAPS IS HIMSELF A FORMER
OBAMA SECURITY OFFICIAL AND
MIGHT HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT
DISCLOSING THAT IN THE
CONVERSATION.
AND FINALLY DID NBC HIRE ALEX
JONES?
>> THIS BIZARRO TREASURE HUNT
FOR DIRT ON OUR OWN INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES TO TRY TO SET UP
RUSSIA'S INTERFERENCE IS A FALSE
FLAG OPERATION.
ACCORDING TO THE CONSPIRACY,
RUSSIA DIDN'T DO THAT, RUSSIA
DIDN'T INTERVENE.
WHAT HAPPENED IS THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THAT WAS SETTING
THIS ALL UP AS A FRAME JOB.
>> I ACTUALLY FELT BAD FOR THE
FOLKS OVER AT THE OTHER NETWORKS
LAST NIGHT.
THE NEWS CAME LATE AND THEY
DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO FULLY
PROCESS IT OR AND MARINATE IN
IT.
AT SOME TINFOIL HATS MIGHT HAVE
BEEN ON A LITTLE TOO TIGHT.
THE SAME PEOPLE SPENT TWO YEARS
OF COURSE PROMOTING THE RUSSIA
HOAX AND THEY HYPED EVERY DETAIL
OF THE MOLAR PROBE CLAIMING IT
WASN'T POLITICALLY MOTIVATED.
AND INSTEAD OF EMBRACING OF AN
INVESTIGATION BY HIGHLY
RESPECTED ATTORNEY, THEY ARE
LASHING OUT AND TRYING TO
DISCREDIT DURHAM OF ALL PEOPLE
WHO HAS BIPARTISAN ACCOLADES FOR
HIM, BUT NOT ANY LONGER.
AND HE HAS TO FINISH HIS WORK.
JOINING ME NOW IS
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, AND VICTOR DAVID
HANSEN, SENIOR FELLOW AT THE
HOOVER INSTITUTION.
THIS IS HAPPENING EXACTLY HOW
YOU SAID IT WOULD.